Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in
the audience. We do these calls once a
week via Discord at David Pakman dot com
slash discord, and it is a great thing.
It's a shame we can't do it more. I would say
much to the chagrin of many in our audience.
Let's start today. Oh, I don't know. Let's go
to Canada. Let's start with Jason from Toronto.
Hey, Dave, how are you doing? I'm
doing well, thank you for asking.
Speaker 3: Thanks for taking my call
again. I actually spoke to you recently
about Putin and Russia and the impact that
that would have with Trump in power. So
thanks for taking my call again. Just a quick
question. Not really political or politics
related, but more. Just a personal question.
What do you enjoy most about what you do?
Speaker 1: Honestly, it's that I it's not really
a real job in the sense of like, I don't have an
annoying boss or have to go anywhere or anything
like that. It's just the autonomy, I would say.
Speaker 3: Awesome. I know that you've
been doing this for a while now. How
many years have you been had your show?
Speaker 1: I think about 80 years now.
Speaker 3: That's awesome. Well,
anyways, thanks for taking my
call. It was just a simple question, right?
Speaker 1: And things are good in Canada.
Speaker 3: Yeah, things are things are good. We
still have a little bit of snow here in southern
Ontario, which is really annoying, but I'll be
in the states in a couple of weeks. So I'm kind
of excited to go somewhere warmer is.
Speaker 1: Is Ontario hostile to
poutine because it's just too French?
Speaker 3: Oh, no, it's just less prevalent
around here, but people embrace the food just
as they would in Montreal or across Canada, so
Speaker 1: that's good news. I'm pleased by
that, at least for sure. All right, thank you
for the call. Great to talk to you. Take care. All
right, there is Jason from Toronto. What a day.